i think i have this theory that certain
subjects should be taught at a later
point in someone's life
yeah that's a good point why is school
done the way it is let's fix school real
quick
i think that they're trying to change it
up right to where it's like they're
trying to cater to different type of
intelli like different types of
intelligences because i think that
what we grew up in was like traditional
classroom learning this is how it's
going to be
and the ones that fail are just the ones
that fail and it's like that's not true
if that's
this setup it just does not curtail to
that person's type of
intelligence or needs right i'll give
you an example i did a i
this is so probably georgia was in
first second or third grade like before
then it was it was before third
grade and i i've chaperoned a trip
to some it wasn't it was like uh
what's it called when they on arbitorium
or arboretum arboretum arbor
or yeah with plants yeah in trees
alberto yeah and so i shop around a trip
and
now i only have girls so i only know how
to deal with girls i don't i don't
technically like boys personally like
little boys punch in the balls and if
it's not your kid you don't know how to
handle it so you're like
hey man i can [ __ ] light you up right
now but i can't because you're not my
kid
so a hey buddy we don't punch in the
dick so like
so i uh so they go hey you chaperone the
boys i go i want to shop around the
girls
and they're like no the girls are gonna
be dealt with a mom you can't take him
to the bathroom and stuff and i was like
[ __ ] so i get stuck with these boys i've
never dealt with a boy i
don't have a boy i don't [ __ ] with boys
and i know i'm sitting with these boys
we're eating lunch under a tree and this
one boy says
i bet i could hit that bird with a stick
and the bird's pretty far away and i'm
like i guarantee you can't
and he's like i bet i could and i was
like try and so he grabs his stick
and from like 20 yards he brains it just
and feathers are [ __ ] everywhere and
i'm like
holy [ __ ] it's like i told you and i was
like and now the moms are losing their
[ __ ] they're like what the [ __ ] girls
are crying
what the [ __ ] are you doing and in my
head this is where my brain's going
i was like you're chastising talent
you're chastising
an arm a natural hunter yeah 400 years
ago he'd be our leader
yeah i'd be telling i'd be trying to
sell my daughter to him for a cow
i'd be like this [ __ ] kid is our
leader he killed a bird
yeah and i didn't know how to parent
that moment other than
literally as he was on time out just
going over going you killed it bro
like and he was like i know i was like
don't listen to the moms like you did
what you're supposed
to do like granted you killed an
innocent animal
for no reason at all at noon under a
tree
if i was his mom i would make him
retrieve the bird pluck all the feathers
and cook it himself
yeah follow through follow through if
you're gonna be a hunter let's be
the best hunter in the world yeah i like
it and you're gonna honor and pray over
its dead body and say i'm sorry but
thank you for
thank you for this food and then eat it
and that's your
[ __ ] noontime snack little boy yeah i
want to see that kid
by the way i know his dad still um and
i'm and i
i can track the kid the kid's like
[ __ ] six two now oh
16 years old six two is he a bird
assassin still i don't know but i'm
telling you if i can get my daughter
near him
you know what's crazy i started i
started like becoming fans of
so like there's boys that come up in
your i
consider like jake paul a boy like i
don't i mean obviously he could beat me
up and everything but like
he could also be my child right i mean
what's he doing yeah he's he's like 18
years old
right logan paul 18. he's got to be 18
20 years old he's only 35 we just
no way jake ball is 24. yeah he's a boy
he's looking at 25.
yeah he's a bad whoa talk about irish
twins
anyway that's when uh apparently
breastfeeding isn't a contraceptive huh